ahora es el turno de las restas haremos
la siguiente resta 9.05 menos 3.6
haremos lo mismo que hemos hecho con las
sumas acomodar de nuevo estos números
pero siempre alineados por el punto así
es que empezamos tendremos
9 005 y el punto que separa las unidades
y las décimas está aquí y haremos lo
mismo con el de abajo
tres unidades seis décimas
así es que ahora podemos hacer la resta
esta vez es una resta y como hemos hecho
las restas anteriormente vemos que el 3
sin duda es más pequeño que el 9 por lo
que podremos hacerlo vamos a rellenar
como lo hemos hecho también las columnas
que nos quedan y así podemos tener
columnas completas los pongo en blanco
porque es opcional podemos hacer
entonces ya nuestras restas tenemos que
cinco menos cero es igual a 500 es igual
a cero y aquí tenemos que cero menos
seis cuánto será este cero nos está
causando conflictos ocupamos pedirle a
la columna de las unidades recuerda que
una unidad es igual a 10 decimos
entonces este 9 lo convertiremos en 8 y
estaremos pasando 10 décimos hacia la
derecha por lo que ahora tenemos que 10
+ 0 es igual a 10
10 - 6 es igual a 4 y 8 menos 3 es igual
a 5
acuérdense siempre siempre siempre de
llevarse el punto de tal manera que no
se nos olvide y todos quedemos alineados
una vez mas 9.00 5 - 3.6 es igual a
5.400 5 lo que es igual a 5 unidades
estamos antes del punto 405.000 decimos
vamos claros nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo